THE U.S. HOUSE SPEAKER IS IN JAPAN
RIGHT NOW, WHERE SHE HAS
DEFENDED HER TOUR, INCLUDING
THE CONTROVERSIAL STOP TO
TAIWAN.
CHINA HAS FURTHER PROTESTED
THAT THIS VISIT, WITH A NEW
SHOW OF FORCE.
TEHRAN SAYS THAT SEVERAL
CHINESE WARSHIPS AND JETS HAVE
CROSSED THE LINE OF THE TAIWAN
STRAIGHT.
ANOTHER LARGE NUMBER OF PLANES
HAVE ENTERED IT CERTIFICATION'S
OWN.
BEIJING ALSO DISPLAYED ITS
ANGER BY ANNOUNCING SANCTIONS
AGAINST NANCY PELOSI, AND
SUSPENDING SOME COOPERATION
WITH WASHINGTON.
THE U.S. SAYS THAT CHINA IS
OVERREACTING.
LET'S GET MORE FORM NOW FROM
SELINA WANG IN BEIJING, AND IT
TOUCHES WASHINGTON.
LET ME START WITH, YOU CHINA'S
SANCTIONING HOW SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI AND HER FAMILY, AND ALSO
REFUSING TO COOPERATE WITH THE
U.S. AND A WHOLE HOST OF
ISSUES.
INCLUDING DEFENSE, DRUG
SMUGGLING, AND YOU CAN EVEN
CLIMATE.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
WE ARE SEEING CHINA COME FULL
FORCE WITH THE WHOLE ARRAY OF
RETALIATION AND BACK LASHED IT
DRAMATICALLY, ECONOMICALLY AND
MILITARILY OF COURSE.
AND NOW IT IS SINKING U.S.
CHINA RELATIONS TO A NEW LOW.
AS YOU MENTIONED THEY ARE
SANCTIONING HOW SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI AND HER IMMEDIATE FAMILY
AND HAVE NOT YET SHARED ANY
INFORMATION OR DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT THAT WILL ENTAIL BUT IT IS
A HIGHLY SYMBOLIC MOVE.
AND NOT CRITICALLY, THEY ARE
ANNOUNCING THAT THEY ARE
CUTTING OFF DIALOGUE WITH THE
U.S. AND A WIDE ARRAY OF AREAS
AS YOU SAY IN CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS A REALLY BIG DEAL
BECAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE IS ONE
OF THE ONLY AREAS WHERE THE
U.S. AND CHINA WERE CONTINUING
TO CONSISTENTLY SPEAK TO EACH
OTHER DESPITE THE HEIGHT
INTENTION OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE CUTTING
OFF DIALOGUE IN THESE KEY AREAS,
SHOWS THE STATE OF U.S. AND
CHINA RELATIONS TODAY.
JUST HOW MUCH MISTRUST THERE IS
BETWEEN THE TWO SIDES, IT
REMAINS TO BE SEEN IF THE
IMPACT OF THIS IS REVERSIBLE.
ON THE MILITARY FRONT, WE ARE
SEEING SHOT I COULD TO DO THE
RUSSIAN OPPOSITE SIMULATION OF
TAIWAN, CONTINUING TO FLY A
LARGE NUMBER OF WARPLANES INTO
TAIWAN'S SELF-DECLARED AND AIR
DEFENSE ZONE.
IT'S THE AIRSPACE AROUND TAIWAN
AND A VERY INFLAMMATORY MOVE
YESTERDAY ACCORDING TO CHINESE
STATE MEDIA.
MISSILES FROM CHINA FLEW OVER
TAIWAN ISLAND FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
NOT AROUND IT BUT OVER IT AND
THIS IS SEEN AS A MAJOR
ESCALATORY MOVE AND THAT
MILITARY TELLS ME GO BEYOND
WHAT THEY EXPECTED CHINA TO DO.
AND SAY NOW THIS IS PART OF A
DAYS-LONG MILITARY GEL THAT IS
HAPPENING AND ESSENTIALLY A
CIRCLE AROUND TAIWAN.
AND WHAT CHINA HAS CALLED A
SIMULATION BLOCKADE.
THE MESSAGE CHINA IS THAT LEAD
TO THE MESSAGES THAT OUR
POWERFUL IN MODERN MILITARY HAS
THE ABILITY TO CHOKE TAIWAN OFF
FROM THE REST OF THE WORLD AT
ANY MOMENT.
BUT WHEN I SPEAK TO MILITARY
EXPERTS AND THEY ALSO SAY LOOK.
THESE MILITARY DRILLS AND THEY
TAKE A LONG TIME TO PLAN AND
THEY COULD NOT HAVE PLANNED ALL
OF THIS JUST WHEN THEY FOUND
OUT PELOSI MIGHT HAVE BEEN
VISITING TAIWAN.
SOME OF THIS HAS BEEN A YEAR IN
THE MAKING.
AND THEY MADE SOME TWEAKS TO
THEIR OLD OUTLINE WHEN THEY
FOUND OUT ABOUT PELOSI'S
POTENTIAL VISIT.
BUT BY PEGGING ALL OF THIS
MILITARY ACTIVITY TO HOUSE
SPEAKER, NANCY PELOSI'S VISIT,
IT'S CREATING A LOT OF
PATRIOTISM AND NATIONALISM AT
HOME.
FOR PEOPLE AT CHINA WHO SAY
THIS WAS A DIRECT THREAT TO OUR
SOVEREIGNTY.
AND WE WANTED TO SEE A BIG
RESPONSE AND THERE IS A PRICE
TO BE PAID FOR PROVOKING CHINA.
IT IS A WELCOME DISTRACTION AS
WELL, THE CHINESE LEADER XI
JINPING AND THE ECONOMY HERE IS
STRUGGLING UNDER THE WEIGHT OF
CHINA'S CONTINUING ZERO COVID
POLICY.
>> ALL RIGHT LET ME BRING IN
NATASHA NOW.
SO NATASHA, OBVIOUSLY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO GENERALIZE THE
THOUGHTS, FEELINGS AND OPINIONS
OF 330 MILLION PEOPLE.
HAS THE WAY AMERICANS PERCEIVE
NANCY PELOSI, HAS THAT CHANGED
AND THE WEIGHT OF HER VISIT TO
TAIPEI?
>> IT IS REALLY HARD TO SAY BUT
LOOK, THIS WAS VERY WIDELY
RECOGNIZED AS KIND OF A LEGACY
TRIP BY NANCY PELOSI.
THIS WAS LIKELY HER LAST TIME
IN CONGRESS, SHE WANTED TO
CONVEY TO THE WORLD THAT SHE IS
TOUGH ON CHINA.
THAT IS THE REPUTATION THAT SHE
HAS HAD FOR MANY DECADES,
SHOWING THE WORLD THAT SHE IS
WILLING TO STAND UP TO THE
CHINESE ANALYSIS ON THEN SHE
WANTED TO DO ON ONE OF HER LAST
POTENTIAL, LAST MAJOR FOREIGN
TRIPS.
ESPECIALLY AS THE HOUSE
SPEAKER.
AND NOW THE WHITE HOUSE OF
COURSE HAS BEEN DISCOURAGING
HER FOR MANY WEEKS BUT FROM
TAKING THE STRIP BECAUSE THEY
VIEWED IT AS POTENTIALLY
ESCALATORY.
AND AS WE HAVE SEEN, THEY ARE
MORE SUSPICIONS AND FEARS HAVE
COME THROUGH.
WITH THE MAJOR CHINESE RESPONSE
THAT WE ARE SEEING AROUND
TAIWAN.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE WHITE
HOUSE IS SAYING, THAT CHINA'S
ACTIONS HERE ARE NOT
PROPORTIONAL.
NOT A HOUSE SPEAKER HAS VISITED
TAIWAN IN THE PAST, AND THAT
THE UNITED STATES HAS ONE CHINA
POLICY ON POLICY TOWARDS TAIWAN
HAS NOT CHANGED EITHER.
THEY STILL BELIEVE THAT TAIWAN
SHOULD NOT BE INDEPENDENT AND I
VISIT BY THE SPEAKER HAS NOT
CHANGED THAT VIEW.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO CONVEY
TO THE CHINESE AND WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE CONVEY TO THE
CHINESE AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S.
WHEN THEY SUMMONED HIM TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, JUST YESTERDAY.
IS THAT IT IS CHINA'S ACTIONS
NOW THAT ARE UNPRECEDENTED, NOT
THE UNITED STATES.
AT THE SAME TIME, WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING HERE IS THAT THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO BACK DOWN FROM
THEIR OPERATIONS IN THE WESTERN
PACIFIC.
BECAUSE CHINA HAS ENGAGED IN
THE MILITARY DRILLS.
THAT'S BY THE FACT THAT
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL SPOKESMAN HERE,
IT APPEARS THAT THE UNITED
STATES, AS THOUGH CHINA IS
DELIBERATELY UPPING THE ANTE
HERE IN ORDER TO CREATE A KIND
OF NEW STATUS QUO.
IN ORDER TO PUSH THE UNITED
STATES OUT OF THAT ORBIT, MAKE
IT SO THAT THIS IS NORMALIZED
MILITARY ACTIVITY NEAR TAIWAN
TO PREVENT THE UNITED STATES
FROM FEELING AS THOUGH IT IS
SAFE TO OPERATE THEIR.
THERE IS A LOT OF ESCALATING
TENSIONS HERE, A LOT OF BACK
AND FORTH THAT HAS CONTINUED
BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
CHINA ON THIS.
REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHETHER
CHINA CONTINUES TO ESCALATE IN
THE COMING DAYS, THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYS THEY BELIEVE IT'S
ENTIRELY POSSIBLE.
ZAIN?
>> ALL RIGHT NATASHA, LIVE FOR
US THERE SELINA WANG THANK YOU
BOTH SO MUCH.